Karim Ado replaces the faulty parts of a
Car rear view
mirror his customer wants it repaired as
he can't afford a new
one after several tries the trader
turned Artisan fixed the mirror with
locally fabricated
Parts if you come here with a model that
is higher than what we have we know how
we make it make sure you get what you
want that will serve the same purpose
and the durability is there skilled and
Innovative Nigerians are cashing in on a
surging demand as locals seek to replace
or repair expensive
Imports Karim says even this electric
fan was successfully made here it can
run on a power pack for
[Music]
hours these local products and
secondhand goods are gaining acceptance
among Nigerians hit by hyperinflation
where the Nigerian currency Liv with
more than half its value in four
months economists say the situation is
not just about the depreciation in the
value of the
NAA not only exchange the not only
exchange rate they hiked the cost of
clearing Goods it's now double for
example the car we buy for
$1,700 before now it's around
$8,000 because of that markets like
ladipo are thriving and even struggling
to meet customer demand for locally
manufactured or secondhand
Goods Nigeria is an import dependent
economy that includes refined petroleum
even though it has been Africa's leading
oil producer for many years as a local
currency loses its value and the demand
for foreign cash Rises many businesses
are unable to import parts they need as
they get more expensive and there is a
limit to how many they can make here
themselves if these businesses fail many
Nigerian drivers w't be able to do what
they lost
go driving that means more business and
income for local Enterprises and a
chance for Nigeria to start sourcing
some of its needs locally Ahmed rris Al
jazer Lagos
Nigeria make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer